i gotta tell you i love this movie and i
actually wanted to start because i with
a tweet that i read it went viral like
two days ago and i felt like it really
put into context why a movie like fire
island is so important they wrote white
characters being queer always got to be
hinted at boy looks at another boy for
11 seconds and we gotta take it and
celebrate and make it more than what
they gave and yet
right and yeah
in the first five seconds i mean it is
clear it is gonna get gay
this week is sacred we're going to fire
ireland and this is why straight people
hate us
you know so
heteronormativity judeo-christian
pathology so joel like was that
obviously the movie is so much more than
that but was that kind of like the goal
when you started to write this is to
make a rom-com for queer people where
queer people could see themselves up on
screen for longer than 11 seconds yeah
absolutely i mean i think that for me
setting it in a place like fire island
where there are no straight people
really opened up this this world where i
didn't feel beholden or i didn't feel
like i had to be pedantic or educate
straight people on like what our world
is you know i could just allow these
queer characters to live their authentic
lives and and sort of navigate that
world like like we all do without having
to like stop every five seconds and be
like and this is what this means and
this is you know and like there are no
longing glances there are there's just
full penetration
sometimes not but that's your thing yeah
sometimes not y'all look like you have
the best time making this movie uh
conrad and matt what memories
immediately come to mind about your time
filming on the pines
i think just being able to spend two
weeks in the same house under the same
roof
uh was
i mean just
the opportunity of a lifetime i feel
like i'm surprised that we got paid
because it felt like we were just
hanging out and having fun a lot of the
time it felt like somewhere on the pines
right
yeah yeah yeah i mean
that's the thing is i think what i'll
always take from this experience is that
i became closer with you know my
sister's bowen and joel who i never
thought i could become closer with but
we definitely did but then also like
adding members of a chosen family which
is this entire cast and this cast
really became so close and by the end of
shooting i remember when everyone
wrapped we were crying
like it was truly we wrapped the last
thing we shot was the underwear party
and which kind of felt fitting because
we worked up to it what a way to go out
yeah but yeah and i remember just like
that was such an emotional night and
it's such a testament to how much love
there was on set and you know watching
the movie it really reads that this is a
group of people that loved each other
and um yeah it was that i think one of
the telling things is that when we were
all
shooting group scenes nobody would hang
out in their trailers everybody would
stand at the steps like sit sit outside
together and then matt and bowen and
tomas
uh doing nicki minaj like numbers in
front of for all of us
oh you got a free shirt
yeah
it was like sometimes when it when it
was a scene or like a sequence where not
everyone was there we were like where's
this person that was always like you
know the best times when we were all
together doing those set pieces like the
scene where we had the dinner with
margaret's sitting at the head of the
table at the house like that was such a
great night and there was these bug
remember how big those bugs were oh my
god they were there don't look
[Laughter]
can we please talk about margaret cho in
this i mean how much fun did y'all have
working with her and why was she the
perfect matriarch for this chosen family
well i mean i think margaret had to go
through sort of a gauntlet every day of
gay boys pulling her aside and telling
her how much she meant to them i think
every single person in the cast had i
waited a week
um i mean it's just i think for all she
was formative uh you know her work has
been formative for all of us so i think
it was like huge and it was a nice sort
of like nod to that to have her be our
mom yeah
and she would just spin a yarn like and
tell you a story about like something
that happened
um in the pines or on trevi road when
she would come uh in the past and you
know just someone who's witnessed
so much uh i feel that was just such a
perfect grounding presence that's a
cliche but i mean to say that she paved
the way for
every single one of us is
an understatement it's so true i feel
like she's a pioneer in so many ways and
that's what made i don't know her being
this so
special and full circle and not only is
this movie a celebration of the queer
experience but it does feature
predominantly asian-american cast so i
mean bowen for you how empowering does
it feel to be part of i don't know this
kind of representation
in this film on screen
well with what
what we've been talking about is that
you go to fire island and you feel like
this weight has been lifted off you
don't have to explain yourself and
explain your queerness and the way that
joel wrote it is that you know that kind
of is seamlessly worked in and i i feel
the same way in terms of
the intersectionality of it i felt the
same way in terms of my asian identity
you know like these characters don't
walk around going this is what being
asian was like this is what being asian
is like it's kind of
hinted at or just
touching the surface and towing some
line i feel like
this was i've been lucky enough to be on
sets where it has been predominantly
asian and this felt like something even
more special just just to have
that
those inner locked
pieces um
and then of course you can't have a gay
movie without little britney spears i
mean joel what inspired the britney
spears sometimes karaoke moment like why
was that the perfect song choice um i
mean it was bowen's choice actually it
was always written into the script that
bowen would sing karaoke in that moment
and i asked bone for a list of songs
that he'd be comfortable singing and
sometimes was sort of the top choice and
we were able to get it and
adding matt and tomas was like later and
again i was saying like
matt and tomas created that choreography
without telling anybody um really it was
a
shock and surprise to everybody um when
we started shooting it and uh i i just
can't it's my favorite scene in the
movie for sure so good and then the
cover at the end too i thought that was
a nice little oh my god
a testament to what can happen when you
check your you shoot your shot in
someone's dm because i literally that
came up they came about because i dm'd
muna on twitter bowen want to ask you
about all the changes coming to snl next
season i mean how hard was that last day
on set with 80 and with pete and kate
it was so emotional it is just these
four people who have defined what that
show is in the last decade and
distinct presences distinct voices and
four people who were sort of the best to
ever do it and i i haven't worked there
um
when they haven't so i it's going to be
an interesting
sort of envisioning of the show and
recalibration but i'm excited to see
where it goes yeah we're going to miss
trend forecasters that's for sure i want
to end on a tweet since i started with
the tweet uh
joel you actually commented on this fire
island will be much discussed deservedly
it's great smart sexy nuance i do worry
that in all the deserved discussion the
exquisite shapeliness of rick amara's
legs will go uncommented upon i will not
brooklyn what
oh
this is why
this is why i'm off of all this yeah
still i agree i agree yeah yeah i think
we should have gotten more uh long shots
of conrad's entire body 18 should
dedicate one story to his legs yeah i
think that's why you experienced the
shapeliness of them who is it shapely
those
[Music]
you